hey guys welcome back to planet coaster
this is the last episode of the season
if you may call it that and there are a
number of things I want to talk about
regarding this series in general also
the game planet coaster in general and
the comment section of the last video
and they're actually not that many
things I want to talk about regarding
this video because truth be told this
time-lapse is mainly me just finishing
the park to at least get it to be
presentable States to make it available
for download and make a video of it but
what I do wanna make quite clear is that
I haven't really finished this Park in a
sense that it's not a finished park
there are just certain areas just left I
was planning many more flat rides in
some of the areas as well there was
still one more like large area I wanted
to make and the park is just far from
finished
I just sort of had Li 24th as a deadline
as in I wanted to finish the park and
get it up before the 24th because I'm
really not sure if this park will
survive the update not to mention
there's obviously the issues with the
lag as well so the only thing I really
wanted to do in this time-lapse time I
recorded is to generally finish the park
with mostly some foliage around it and
some coming soon well banners which are
all just hoping that this park is still
going to work in alpha-2 but I don't
think it really will which does mean
that it is a bit of a small timeframe
here since it'll be downloadable from
probably the end of the 23rd maybe the
end of the 22nd today that is but there
won't be a lot of time to actually look
at the park if alpha 2 comes out and it
turns out that you can't really open the
park on it so I also want to get the
video out before they 24th and hopefully
that is all going to work out well now
about the video because this is
something that I wanted to talk about
the series in general but also many of
the comments that I got on the last
video I don't think I ever made this
really clear but my intention has always
been from the beginning to make a so the
final video of the park with some
generally cinematic shots and some POVs
of the rollercoasters it's more or less
a thing that I've always done and
something which I expected
I would do in this series but of course
not something that I expected other
people to expect if that makes any sense
so yeah I will make a video in which
I'll show off the coaster POVs if I get
it to work and have a nice little tour
of the park to show it off one last time
though I also have to say I'm quite
optimistic with that and I'm not
entirely sure if it's really going to
work in the end because it will require
cheap engine to hopefully get the park
to a well hopefully get the videos to a
respectable frame rate because I at the
moment run 8 fps in the game can be even
lower if the game is not paused and
especially on coaster POVs it's really
bad so the hopes are that slowing it
down with cheatengine about 6 times
maybe even 8 times and then speed it up
in post-production is something that is
going to at least give some pretty
smooth videos and be less bad than the
lag in the game and that's hopefully how
I'll be able to make that sort of video
so yeah about all the comments about
whether I'll do a tour of the park or
whether I'll show of any POVs I'll do
both of that but when it comes to those
videos I do usually just make it a sort
of cinematic video so there won't be any
like commentary or things like that it's
just showing off the park with I guess
some nice camera angles and some nice
music in the background something along
the lines of thoughts so yeah those are
my plans for this park at the moment and
that's also why this last video is sort
of nothing really special and doesn't
really feel like an entire video as much
as the rest of the videos because there
isn't any sort of central focus there
isn't anything really interesting being
built it's just sort of finishing the
things that still needed finishing which
are mostly some of the boring stuff like
doing some extra rock work adding some
of the foliage
around the park and a few path elements
and fences just to make things a little
bit nicer that said if it turns out that
the park actually opens correctly in
alpha 2 which I seriously doubt but if
it actually happens I have kept a large
number of saves of the park over a good
amount of time as well so that there are
different safe states and there
is one just before this episode or
halfway through this episode there are
two as well so only off chance that it
still works in alpha 2 I might be able
to get back to this park at some point
in the future and maybe finish it but
then again the most important thing of
the park was and in hindsight I'm kind
of glad I went for this approach in
general was to just experiment with
different styles and just have like sort
of separate areas of things to
experiment with because in the end it
may not be a completely finished park
and I doubt it ever will become one and
I definitely have a few gripes about the
way it's laid out and things like that I
am actually really happy with how the
sort of individual parts came out and
it's obviously just amazing practice as
well I know that I like to bash my own
work in my videos too often perhaps
though I think it's maybe not even often
enough I think one of the most amazing
things about this park so far has been
that it's actually been an amazing
learning experience and I know it sounds
really really Krrish Krrish a what I
know it sounds really cliche
I'm not going to rerecord that anyway I
know it sounds really cliche but it's
just something that I generally think it
was my main aim and it actually came out
a lot better than I ever hoped for or
expected in the end came out with a good
number of buildings and some themes
which I never expected beforehand and
actually got some awesome reception as
well which I really have to thank you
guys for as well so seriously thank you
guys for following this series so far
that's a weird thing to say in the
middle of a video but anyway yeah I
really want to thank you all for
watching this series so far now about
the future because that's probably
something I should Segway into right now
I actually I'm not entirely sure anymore
I know that last time I slept that I
would make a new park and make it sort
of Disney style ish but I do have to say
that right about the 24th right now is
not really the greatest planning for me
life wise in terms of having exams and
final papers and some other things I
need to work on so I don't exactly have
a lot of time which I also said was one
of the reasons why I
probably won't start a new series very
soon but I may also not start one new
Park series but maybe just focus on
coasters as in standalone coasters and
make them sort of smaller projects
before I move into a larger park because
given how much time it took to make
grizzly Valley I am not entirely sure if
I can make like one enormous park in
just between alpha 2 and alpha 3 being
released and actually be happy with it
and actually finish it before sort of
the deadline of alpha 3 arrives at that
point in time so maybe especially also
given the fact that alpha 2 is mostly
about the coasters and terraforming I
may want to just make some separate
coasters like I also did in the good old
days but yeah I'm not entirely sure
about that so yeah if you would ask me
about my future plans I'm not entirely
sure if I'm going to make one large park
and try to somehow make it before the
deadline and not end up in this grizzly
Valley scenario where it just ends up
being released half unfinished or
whether I'll just make a bunch of
coasters with a bunch of different
themes and make them standalone sort of
coasters in their own little parks
because the other advantage of doing
that is that I won't run into any
computer problems which also will make
it possible to work a lot faster because
even if 8 frames per second isn't really
a problem for me mentally it's just
something that makes workflow an
incredibly a lot slower and it's not
really great and when you're making
videos that way so yeah I might just
make some standalone coasters the themes
that I mentioned though are still
probably going to be some of the themes
I want to mess around with like I really
want to get into some of the more
fantasy like themes so Western is
something I'm thinking about
Viking kind of style is also something
that I've got some comments about and
definitely something I am considering as
well as well as some of the like
different fantasy styles be its Middle
Eastern fantasy or Alpine fantasy just
fun themes which with which you can do a
lot and also make use of the well they
may new additions to the game because
truth be told the terraforming is
definitely going to
a huge addition so the things that I do
make I definitely want to get used to
the terraforming and sort of sort of get
experience with it and take that with me
for the upcoming updates of the game and
the same goes for rollercoaster since
it's a really big addition not just
because there are new types but also
because we can finally actually recolor
the tracks and trains as well I believe
I saw a recent forum post about of the
roller coasters it's definitely going to
be a big game changer and what I am
probably going to want to focus my
videos of alpha-2 on so yeah those were
sort of my really vague plans but yeah
also my reasons why I'm not entirely
sure what to do with those plans yet and
I'm not entirely sure which one of those
plans to choose and in the end I might
probably just choose for whatever I feel
works and I still sort of have to open
the second alpha because as I would
always do or always try to do I kind of
do want to open a new update of the game
before I sort of make videos of it and
just try some things and see what's new
and see how you can work with it
so definitely won't start making things
of the new Alpha right when it comes out
also I still have a dark ride which I
started halfway through alpha 1 which
I'm not going to spoil too much about
but it's sort of like an illusion kind
of dark ride with not being sure whether
you're upside down or sideways or things
like that but it was a complete pain to
make with the rotation system of alpha 1
but alpha 2 rotations system is actually
really handy for making that kind of
ride so I might actually get into a dark
ride at some point in alpha 2 as well
just something that I'm working on I
guess and you know working on these
smaller things these sort of side
projects or the different themes and
buildings within grizzly Valley without
looking at the big picture too much a
something I feel does fit the game at
this stage a bit more and I don't go
into like a review of planet coaster too
much because that's not the type of
person I or not the type of videos I
really make but um that's it's what I
feel the game is sort of a phase in
right now which is it's just still sort
experimental and just taking things one
step at a time and I kind of want to do
that with the videos as well so planet
coaster so far is an amazing game I
think at least but it's just so limited
and it's still like in one of the very
earlier steps of its entire development
and it's just looking at a few things of
the entire like coaster building genre
in general and I find many people like
praised it a lot already and claim that
it's already amazing for an alpha game
but I do feel well it's really good that
was it what it does so far it's it
hasn't really done much yet and there is
a lot more to come still and is it going
to be an entire theme park simulation
game there is still a lot of things that
it still has to do and so that's also
one of the reasons why I don't like
focus too much on creating enormous
parks already there aren't really many
themes yet there aren't really many
attractions or rollercoasters yet it's
just more on these smaller things so
just trying to see what we can do with
the things that we have right now so you
can sort of get into that more with
upcoming updates and combine it with
what's going to be new in upcoming
updates and yeah that's basically what
I'm gonna still try to do and hence sort
of the same approach still in the next
series that is going to be in alpha 2
that I had with alpha 1 and I'm still
not going to really focus on just making
the like exact theme parks work but more
just focus on specific things at a time
anyway that's right about it for today I
still had like a couple of time lapse
things which I cut out and I don't have
much else that I really wanted to say in
this video so yeah I should say if you
still have any questions or maybe
suggestions or feedback on how I can
improve the park or anything else in the
future
be sure to leave a comment about it and
I'll check it out and also I'll give a
downloads to this Park in the
description of this video so if you want
to have it then you can scroll down a
bit and download it from there
at least until the 24th and hopefully
it'll work from that point onward anyway
thank you guys for watching this series
and I hope to see you guys in the next
one